hey yeah look I had I had an outfit to
match the 9th doctor I don't really have
one to match the 10th doctor so I don't
know what I'm gonna do when when we get
into his later episodes but this one
exists in his pajamas mine no matches
but just do the credits
[Applause]
[Music]
the Christmas invasion the first proper
episode for david tennant since i did
for some reason devote an entire video
to the short that technically kind of
give us a first taste of him but here
this is generally considered the first
proper adventure for the doctor it's the
one that i know a lot of people have a
lot of fun memories about and i have
mixed feelings about I've kind of always
had mixed feelings about that said as
has frequently been the case in going
back and revisiting these it is nice to
be reminded that the stuff that is good
even in the episodes that I'm not the
biggest fan of is often times stronger
than I remember it being I think what
tends to happen is as time goes on in
your memory does what memory does any
kind of fades and things blur together a
little bit you tend to focus more if
your overall impression of an episode
was negative you tend to focus much more
on that element of it because that's
what left a stronger impression and your
impression of the positive stuff starts
to fade and become a little bit more
background noise to the point where
maybe if you even still recognize that
there was good stuff in it you think
well I guess they wasn't that good but
no the stuff that is good in here is
really good there's still a fair amount
of stuff I don't care for but yeah we'll
get into that so we've got the doctor
out of commission which is in a lot of
ways I think the biggest detriment to
this particular episode like I get it I
understand sort of why it was done in
terms of the sort of mechanics of
getting the plot into place you know
giving yeah it feels like in some in
some way like almost a period of
mourning that that Eccleston is gone and
you know gives us a chance for ROS to
really kind of vent her fear and her
frustration or sadness at the loss and
none of that is bad stuff but like
ultimately there's really only two times
that I I'm
really actively engaged by this episode
ones when the doctors actually on-screen
you know not just sleeping they're going
and the others went Harriet Jones is on
because this this absolutely did
reinforce my placement of her for at the
top of my list of recurring non
companions because she's great she's
awesome in this and it also reaffirms my
feelings that the doctor was overly
harsh on her and within the context of
the episode I can still kind of like
fine we'll go with that
but I do alternate Lee still feel like
the show did her wrong because I feel
like it's not just a matter of the
doctor taking her down but I feel like
in many ways the show it it really does
feel structured that we are supposed to
side with him against her and it no I
don't like I initially I get it in terms
of you know her blasting the cigarette
ship you know as they're leaving but
then honestly she makes a really good
case for why she did that
none of which the doctor actively
refutes he just goes back to his sort of
initial point that she's already made a
really good argument against so you know
between her earlier parents is the fact
that she is so caring about the people
under her that she still has no
presumption that anyone knows who she is
yet at the same time she wields her
authority with authority whether she is
talking to her cabinet whether she is
giving instructions of what should be
told to the American president whether
she's communicating with the cigarettes
there is always a sense of strength but
there's also that very British
you know politeness owed has anyone
offered you tea kind of thing and it's a
wonderful mix it's a wonderful character
and I just yeah I just think the doctor
and kind of the show did her wrong
I will say it's funny that you know
having since this aired in the ensuing
decades having had kind of more of an
opportunity as an adult to really pay
attention to women in politics and how
they are sometimes treated by the media
and by you know the the people who may
not like them in the position that
they're in when this when this when I
saw this for the first time the whole
idea of her being brought down with the
six words doesn't she look tired just
seemed very far-fetched and I remember
thinking wait does the thing is the
doctor like have hypnosis that he pushed
this as hard what what happened there
except that you know I again haven't
gone through life I've now seen sort of
the how quickly the slightest hint of
doubt in female leadership so often
snowballs into things that are
ridiculous that it's not nearly as
far-fetched as I once thought it I
should get off that top because I'm shy
have no doubt there are people who are
gonna vehemently argue with me on that
point so let me get off this so you
don't feel the need to tenant as the
doctor he's great right off the bat he
he I mean it feels triumphant when he
comes back when he opens the door goes
did you miss me yes I did and no don't
argue me that all the downtime made that
moment work like ultimately I don't feel
like this episode justifies the our
length that it has because the way then
it stretches it out is by putting the
doctor out of commission and filling it
with stand-in dangers that have nothing
to do with a bigger story ie killer
Christmas tree or a la Santa's neither
which I like both of which I think are
kind of dumb and I know you know it
seems like some audiences for the most
part British audiences in particular or
at least my impression is that they're
much more forgiving them this cuz
there's you know there's just that sense
of oh it's just a fun goofy Christmas
episode don't be a grump about it don't
be a Scrooge I'm like I'm I can have fun
at Christmas but this is dumb I'm sorry
but again like when when Tennant is
on-screen and active he's phenomenal he
really is great like the point at which
he cuz I can tell you when each doctor
sort of grabbed me and with Eccleston it
was you know I've mentioned it before
you know nice to meet you rose run
my life like that was it with Tennant it
was him
responding to the sick racks going who
are you he's going our Joe no then he
goes through this ramble of all these
character traits like get my this am i
bad am i this is am i bad
judging by the evidence have certainly
got a gob they I just oh love it like
that if I were a nitpick I don't love
the Lion King quote I mean partly
there's part of me that just doesn't
like the doctor quoting pop culture like
I can roll with him having met like
basically every notable historical
figure ever but I'd like I don't know
something about him quoting pop culture
just doesn't sit right with me and it
honestly it probably doesn't help that I
know the Lion King so well that I caught
that quote within probably the first
five words into it and then it goes on
for a little bit longer than that I'm
just sitting there going just stop stop
stop stop
but that's like the only moment with him
that is at all if he for me which is
interesting in hindsight because he's
much more action-oriented here than I
usually like the doctor to be like the
whole idea of doctor getting into sword
fights as something in general that I'm
kind of iffy on I there's nothing
inherently wrong with a more action II
doctor as long as that's not his first
immediate impulse you know I don't have
a problem with him going that route when
necessary but at the same time is sort
of just not my preference and I do have
to say like the the sword fight scene is
shot really badly it's shot and cut
together really really poorly it looks
like crap there's one shot in particular
that's like a long shot and the two
fighters are like down here like what
what is that like this is just blank sky
it's not like an artistic shot where
there's something here that you can see
and then their doubt no this is one
really weird ship there's a number of
shots like that and the cuts are weird
like it's a bad it's a badly presented
fight but again his energy really does
carry it the sicker axe I in
I've no need to ever see them again but
I kind of like the the sort of
self-important nature of them the whole
I did like the hand gets tipped on its
like sick racks rock it's like yeah like
in the modern vernacular sense we rock
that's great
I love the whole blood control thing and
with the doctor sort of just pulling the
rug out from under them with the with
their big threat for what they were
gonna do and I also loved the
implication of that line you know I've
seen blood controlling years that like
this is this is old stuff
so I loved that he just kind of takes
the wind out of their sails so harshly
and I kind of like the idea of the see
crack ship being this just chunk of land
like I don't know if it's an asteroid or
a chunk of our home planner who knows
but I kind of like that as a ship
concept so that's all good stuff Rose is
pretty good here you get you get the
start of that kind of flirty energy
between her and Tennant which if you
like it fine here's where it starts I
it's not they have good chemistry I get
why the show sort of starts going going
down that road I don't like it because I
don't like that kind of relationship
between the doctor and companion I never
will I'll try not to complain about it
too much as the series goes on but yeah
that's not something I've ever really
cared too much for Mickey and Jackie I
think we get just about the right amount
of dose of them may be a little less
Jackie would have been nice but did you
know bits it's nice to have them back
and overall you know the once it hits
the the homestretch and once the doctor
wakes up it goes pretty well it's a it's
a really nicely done thing but again
it's just the whole thing is just
stretched out a little bit too much to
fill an hour like I can think of like
with the with the blood control thing
the idea is neat and certainly the shot
of everybody standing up on the edges of
the buildings that's kind of unsettling
but like the amount of time between you
know when they establish these people
are under this control oh they're going
after it was like
the whole the sequence takes at least
twice as long as it needs to in terms of
like what was necessary to get the
information across and I overall I just
kind of feel like the this story chose
to fill out an hour by adding some stuff
that didn't really contribute to the
story and by making a handful of things
take longer than they would have
otherwise rather than telling a story
that needed an hour in order to function
properly
so like that bugs me a little bit
oh there's one thing that I really and
this is a minor thing but I love it I
love the the doctor you know thinking
about saving the world than his and is a
you know dressing-gown and and all that
that it's very Arthur Dent now there was
a nice man I loved that it said and
moved on but it is an implication that
Hitchhiker's Guide is is not fiction
it's real and exists in the same
universe as Doctor Who which this is not
the first time that actually got hinted
at back in destiny of the Daleks where
we see the doctor reading a book that is
talked about in the Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy as being a book that
exists in that universe so I kind of
like that they're sort of connecting
those dots again I just that just kind
of as a huge Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy fan it just kind of makes me
smile a little bit I feel like the like
sort of ending on that little ah no
feels like the the best place to end
like I said I know I know I complained a
bit but you know Harriet Jones is great
the doctor is great the episode overall
it's it's never gonna be one of my
favorites but it is nice to be reminded
that the stuff that is good about it is
quite good it just makes up maybe about
half of the episode the runtime or at
least it feels like it takes up about
half maybe it's more like two-thirds but
there's a decent sized chunk of this
that I just don't care about as much and
doesn't engage me or kind of bugs me so
those are my thoughts on the Christmas
invasion what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments well
let's talk about it a whole bunch of
stuff that you can do because there's
buttons and links including one to my
patreon and so you know you want to
support me that way I'd appreciate it
but if you don't don't worry about it
I'll do at least you can check out don't
want to click on those don't worry about
that either because at the end of the
day folks you're the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]